hello and welcome to this video playing
yeah that's a back-to-back
aim read Sookie I'm
you know we had something like that in
an earlier game some days ago if you
look at it in terms of release time on
YouTube
yeah we'll be six the best move
you
you
black can play Quincy it's not terrible
but it was also not
not very
very nice prospector to have the Queen
sitting on c8 whole time
in that yeah they play that stuff here
night a six remarkable
interesting to get some some practice in
this in this line
you
yeah ja mode timeout
you
yeah Black has a couple of choices him
there should be seven or 9797 is a good
move
you
I have a bit of a knowledge advantage
share yes because I've already put in
quite a bit of time into those positions
one revelation was that you can
oftentimes simply sacrifice a pawn
you
the army should take it I mean if he
plays Bishop c2 and
it's already this far he should take it
absolutely it makes absolutely no sense
to play Bishop c2 and not take it
you
now there's Bishop f4 or Bishop III both
move both moves work just wonder what I
should do in this particular case
or Bishop d2 even a bishop d2 is also
possible
now the problem is now my thread is
before b5 and if he moves the night I
will win a seven and most likely than
Bissell will drop as well
before b5 is kind of awful if it hit so
we will see what happens him
I have some time advantage there op8 is
always Bishop f4 as the problem
you
yeah I kind of wondered that game out of
my out of my opening prep
okay now let's think for just a moment
here
probably make my life easy I am if I'm
making a good decision now so it takes
Bishop shanks is extra material but
you can also
we just move the knight to f3 let's say
yeah that is probably the easiest
solution attack the rook attack then
attack the knight so take it
here probably night if one says
something even better
[Music]
94 I cannot play ouch ouch
here winning the night now I come on
be true nobody is that lucky
and I can take that's that's a bit lucky
on my part
maybe at c5
yeah it was a [ __ ] I should have really
probably be more precise here 93 was
strong I am
yeah so I'm not going to look at City
opening or that much you know I mean one
one thing is as I mentioned you can
sacrifice that pawn on b3 leads to very
dangerous play maybe we should be too
but should be seven okay one and now I'm
threatening this and it's very dangerous
for black very very dangerous for black
I can't before rook c8 he can do that
but he's under heavy pressure in this
position he took it and now the problem
is you cannot defend b7 and if that
faults kind of everything is just
hanging so Piedra should be 45 his
desperation
so 93 is better than this one yeah but
neither three should win if I attend
Bishop takes that also should do the
trick but yeah saw this one but I didn't
I actually heard I didn't attend I can
actually hear I can move it away or
double the tech but okay neither a3
should win it really should win but I
overlooked what I overlooked this d4 in
the first place I really absolutely did
not see that when I wanted to do 9a for
I mean hey I didn't spot that discovered
and it was lucky that this was possible
I didn't see it beforehand it was just
luck c5 I have actually rugby to iose
yeah or what group between the bishop
has no good squares and then I have this
one to cover it
yeah I was lucky
yeah it looks a bit like a cheetah
gaming I've got I've got six average
sandy pornos six yeah but I mean like up
here this is basically opening prep so
it has to be close to perfect because
I've checked it all in extensively with
engines so it's basically engine play up
to move 18 and then I was a bit lucky ok
guys thanks for watching